Narrator: When most people
buy a house they need
to borrow money for some part of
the purchase price of the house.
Let's say that we have
a house right over here
and the purchase price is $200,000,
and I want to buy this house,
and I've saved up $40,000.
I have saved up $40,000,
so this is my savings,
so I will use this as a down payment,
but I still need to borrow the rest
of the money in order to get to $200,000.
I'm going to have to get the
balance, the $160,000 as a loan.
The type of loan that
people that people will get,
or that they usually get to buy
a house is called a mortgage.
Mortgage. A mortgage is really just a loan
where if you don't pay the loan off,
the person that you borrowed
the money from gets the house.
Another way to think
about it is it's a loan
that's secured by the house
until you pay off the loan.
When you pay off the loan
it is your house to keep,
but at any point if you don't pay it,
the bank could come and take the house,
and that is called a foreclosure.
Now, what I want to focus on in this video
is the types of mortgage
loans you will typically see,
and give you at least the beginning
of an understanding of how to understand
what these different types of loans mean.
In all of these scenarios,
let's just assume
that I'm in the market to borrow $160,000
for this house I'm about to buy.
If you look at any
financial website or any
of the major search-web portals,
they'll give you quotes
for mortgage rates.
You'll see something like this.
I made these numbers really simple.
Normally, you'll have some decimals here;
5.25%, 4.18%.
I made these numbers a little bit
simpler just to make them simpler.
These are the typical types
of mortgage you will see,
but if you contact mortgage
broker they will have
many, many more types, more exotic types;
but these are the most common
and this is what we'll
cover in this video.
Hopefully they'll give you a sense
of what the other types
of mortgage is like.
A 30 year fixed mortgage
means that your payment
and your interest rate
are fixed over 30 years,
and over the course of those 30
years you will pay off your loan.
In this situation, this is a 30 ...
Let me write it over here, let's
think about a 30 year fixed.
30 year fixed mortgage.
What will happen is you
will have a fixed mortgage
payment every month,
and I'll draw a little bar graph
to show the size of your payment.
You'll see why I'm doing that in a second.
Let me just draw a little
bit of a graph here.
Each of these blocks represent
your monthly payment for that month;
and I'm just going to make up the
number, let's say it is $2,000.
I actually haven't figured out the math
of what is the exact
payment for a 30 year fixed
with a 5% interest rate for $160,000;
but, let's just say, for the sake
of simplicity, it's $2,000 a month.
This height right over here,
let me make it like this.
This is $2,000 a month. $2,000.
This is month 1, then you
will pay $2,000 in month 2.
So on and so forth, all the way.
If you have 30 years times 12 months,
you're going to get all
the way to month 360;
and that is going to be your last payment.
Month 360 is the last payment in year 30,
and you would have paid off your loan.
The interesting thing here
is in the first month,
since you've borrowed
so much from the bank,
you've borrowed $160,000, the interest
that you have to pay on it
is going to be pretty large.
Most of the initial payments
are going to be interest.
I'm going to do the interest
in this magenta color.
In that first payment. Oh, that's
not magenta. This is magenta.
In that first payment it's
going to be mostly interest.
You're going to pay a little
bit off of the actual loan;
so that right there is
your principle payment.
Let's say, after that first
month, the principle part
of that $2,000 is, and
I'm just making up numbers
for the sake of simplicity,
let's say that is $200,
and the interest portion is $1,800.
I'm not actually working it
through with these assumptions.
You don't even have to assume
that's a $160,000 loan,
but the general idea here
is after this first month
you would have paid $200 off of your loan.
If it was $160,000 loan,
after that fist month,
you don't owe $160,000 minus 2,000,
because 1,800 of that was interest.
You now owe $160,000 minus
$200, so you now owe $159,800.
In the next period your interest
is going to be a little bit lower.
It's going to be just a little bit lower,
and your principle, since you're paying
the same fixed payment
of $2,000 every month,
is going to be a little bit higher.
Maybe it's going to be, in the next month,
something slightly higher;
I don't know, $202.
You keep going like that
and the math works out;
they figure out the payment
so that by that last
payment you're paying
very little interest,
you're paying very little interest,
and most of that last
payment is principle.
It's actually being used for the loan,
and then after that last
payment, the loan is paid off.
This will happen over 30
years; this is a 30 year term.
A 15 year fixed is the same exact idea,
except instead of it taking 30 years
to pay off the loan, you're
going to do it over 15 years.
Instead of it being 360 months,
in the 15 year case, it
is going to be 180 months;
and because of that,
your payment for the same
loan amount is going to
be higher every month
because you're paying it off quicker.
You're paying it off in fewer months.
Instead of $2,000 a month,
maybe it is something
like $2,800 a month for the 15 year case.
You're paying it off quicker.
The 5/1 ARM case, and you'll see,
and there are many types of ARMs,
and I'm going to explain to
you in a second what an ARM is,
but the 5/1 is the most typical.
I'll explain what that means in a second.
ARM means 'Adjustable Rate Mortgage.'
Adjdustable
Rate
Mortgage
As you see, in these situations we had
the word 'fixed,' and
they were called fixed
because the interest rate was fixed;
whatever your remaining
loan balance was you paid
the same fixed amount of
interest for the next period.
For this 30 year fixed,
we are being quoted
a 5% fixed rate over the next
30 years; will not change.
For the 15 year, we're
quoted a 4% fixed rate.
For the ARM, the rate can change.
When someone tells you about a 5/1 ARM,
they're actually talking about
something called a hybrid ARM;
but, the general idea behind an adjustable
rate mortgage is the
amount of interest you pay
on your remaining balance will change.
It will change according to some index.
The most typical types of
adjustable rate mortgages
are things like this hybrid
ARM; so this is a hybrid.
A hybrid, it's viewed as
a mixture of 2 things,
or a combination of 2 things.
What a hybrid adjustable rate mortgage is
it has fixed rate for some period of time.
In this case, it's a
fixed rate for 5 years,
then the interest rate
can change once a year
after that, or every 1 years after that.
That's what this right
over here is telling you.
In the case of an adjustable rate mortgage
your payment might look
something like this,
and I'll just make up
numbers for simplicity
just to give you the flavor
of what it might look like.
In the case of a 5/1, your
first 5 years are fixed.
Your first 5 years. Month 1
is going to look like that.
Month 2 is going to look like that.
You go all the way to month 60,
which is the last month in the 5 years
and it's going to look like that.
That's 1, that's month
2, that is month 60.
This is the course of 5 years.
This is over the course of 5 years.
Over the course of 5 years,
the idea is fairly similar.
You're going to pay, some
part of this is going
to be interest, and the remainder is going
to actually be used to pay down the loan.
Each month you're going to pay down
a little bit more of the loan, and you're
going to have to pay a
little less in interest.
Make that a little bit bigger.
You're going to have to pay
a little bit less interest,
because you have less
remaining on your loan,
but by year 5, or month 60, you
still haven't paid your loan off.
Maybe the interest is right over there,
and actually it'll probably
be higher than that.
I don't want to be too exact,
but maybe your interest is
going to be right over here;
and this is what you're
paying down from the loan.
For a hybrid adjustable rate mortgage,
after that 5 year period, the bank
can now change the interest rate.
The interest rate is going to be dependent
on some kind of underlying thing
that everyone is paying attention to.
That underlying thing
increases in interest.
In this 5/1 ARM, it starts
off at a 3% interest.
If, because of the thing that we're paying
attention to, and I'll talk
more about that in a second,
interest rates all of a sudden go up.
Let's say they go up a
lot, then all of a sudden
your payment could increase.
Your payment could increase
because the general
idea behind a 5/1 ARM
is that you are still
going to pay it off in 30 years.
They typically, I should
say, have a 30 year term.
If you just stick with this loan,
you never try to borrow other money
to replace this loan, which
is called a refinance,
if you just stick with this
loan it will take you 30 years
to pay it off, but after the first 5 years
the amount of interest
you pay might actually
change, so your payment
might actually change.
If the interest rate
goes up, all of a sudden
you might have to pay a lot more interest
all of a sudden in month 61, or in year 6.
Let me do that in, I can do that
part in that same blue color.
For year 6, since this is a 5/1 ARM,
they can't change the interest
rate again until year 7,
so you'll pay this constant
amount until year 7.
Then, they can change the rate again.
There usually are some caps
on how much they can
change the rate each year,
or how much they can
change the rate in total;
but it is a little bit riskier because
you really don't know
what your payment might be
in year 6, or year 7, especially
if interest rates go up a lot.
Now, you might be asking what determines
what that new interest rate
is in after the 5 years.
They usually pick some type of index.
The most typical are,
especially in the United States,
treasury securities; so,
they'll look at the 10 year
interest rate that
essentially the government
has to pay when it borrows money,
and they'll usually take
some premium over this.
If the 10 year treasury is at 2%,
the bank might put in your loan documents
that after the initial
5 year fixed period,
you will pay 10 year treasury rate plus,
maybe you'll pay that plus 1%.
You start off paying the 3%, that's fixed
even if the treasury does
all sorts of crazy things,
even if it goes up to
5%, you're just going
to keep paying the 3%
for the first 5 years,
but then in that 6th year, let's say that,
let me write it over here,
let's say that in year 6
the treasury security rate
now has bumped up to 4%, then by contract,
by what's in your loan document,
you're going to have to pay that plus 1%.
Now, your mortgage is
going to reset to have
a 5% rate, have a higher rate.
You might get lucky, though.
Maybe the treasury rate goes down,
maybe it goes to 1%,
and then your mortgage
rate would actually be 1% plus 1%,
so it could actually go down to 2%.
But the general idea is
that's a little riskier,
because you really don't know
how predictable that
payment's going to be.
Most times, if you look
at quoted interest rates,
you'll see that the 30
year fixed rate is higher
than the 15 year fixed rate, which
is higher than the adjustable rate.
That's because the bank, there's a couple
of different forms of risk,
but the bank is taking
the least amount of risk
on the adjustable rate
mortgage, and taking the most
risk on the 30 year fixed.
The biggest risk here, there's
the risk that you don't
pay it off; but that's
why they like to see
a down payment, because they can get
the house back and
hopefully the house doesn't
devalue by more than your down payment.
But, even more than that,
there's an interest rate risk.
Because what happens if
the bank lends you money,
lends you a big chunk of money at 5%,
and that interest rates go up to 6%, 7%,
what if they go up to 10%?
What if the bank's borrowing cost,
the amount of money the
bank has to pay people
to borrow money, goes up to 10%?
Then it will be taking
a loss on your loan,
and they're fixing it
for so long, that's why
they want to make up for some of that risk
by charging you higher interest.
A 15 year loan? A little bit less risk,
so they'll have a little
bit lower interest.
A 5/1 ARM? Even lower risk.
They're only fixed for 5 years,
and then after that this will float
with the prevailing interest
rate on an annual basis.
Hopefully that gives you
a little bit of a primer
of mortgage interest
rates, but I want to really
make sure that you don't, just this video
isn't all you need to take out a loan.
It's super important to
read the fine details
on what's happening with that loan,
especially if you're
buying something more,
if you're taking out a more exotic loan
like an adjustable rate mortgage,
or an interest-only
loan, or an option ARM,
or any of those more exotic things.